- I assume that most Boston slang
is mean towards somebody else.
- That's what I'm assuming.
(lively music)
- [Voiceover] A bubbler, what the hell
do you think that means?
- Like the pub, let's go to the bubbler
and let's get bubbled, bubbly tonight.
- It's when you fart.
- It's gotta be a device with
which you can smoke weed.
- A guy with a lisp, he's
just like bubbling around.
- I thought this was just
Rhode Island and Wisconsin,
but it's a drinking fountain.
A bubbler is a drinking fountain.
- Barrel, um, this is like
a big handle of alcohol.
- Barrel means a lot of things,
like you can have a barrel of anything.
- Like a Boston sport fan's huge beer gut.
- Even if you're just having
fun and they had a barrel.
- They had a barrel last night.
- Yeah, we had a barrel of fun.
(lively music)
- [Voiceover] Dot.
- Dot.
- It's a medical term.
- It's an old person.
- It's the Department of Transportation.
- Ah, you see that dot over there?
- That dot over there is wicked white.
- That dot over there though.
- I think a dot's like just
like an absent-minded friend,
it's like, oh Karen, she's such a dot.
(lively music)
- [Voiceover] Dunks.
- Yeah, it's a, I think
it's a booty reference.
- I immediately want to say sneakers.
- Those are my shoes.
- Yeah, shoes.
- Damn, that girl's got dunk-s.
- In her trunk?
- It's the abbreviation for
Dunkin' Donuts, which is like
church out there.
- Yeah.
- I mean, it's just like a staple.
(lively music)
- [Voiceover] Wiffle.
- Wiffle, that sounds like
something from Harry Potter.
- Red Sox play baseball,
Yankees play wiffle.
- I think it's like a play on a waffle.
They're like (bleep) you, it's
not a waffle, it's a wiffle.
- Hold on, grab that guy,
I'm gonna go grab my wiffle,
we'll really teach him a lesson.
- Exactly, wiffle totally,
it's gotta be a bat.
(lively music)
- [Voiceover] Who has seasonal haircuts?
- We should get wiffles.
- When you doin' it tomorrow?
- Uh, people from California
get wiffles for the first time.